attention everyone please
I'm proud to announce I'll be holding a
competition to find my latest wingman
wait what happened to Derek Derek tore
his ACL judging the wet t-shirt
Nationals Kalin no one wants to be a
wing person benefits include one free
drink after a two-drink minimum
well I'm married and I've actually only
been drinking your Bamonte a lately so I
don't know why I even look up okay
whoever wingman's for me I promise to
not bother for one full week and what
would constitute successful way many
international rules will apply a
successful wingman must initiate one
conversation with a girl that
conversation must include some kind of
physical touching and that girl must
contact me within 24 hours by the
electronic means of her choice all right
I meant excellent interviews will be in
conference room B and Elliott put on a
tie
did you shave yeah it's an interview so
Elliot if I were to fight a bear how
would I do
where's it pretty strong may I ask how
much honey you're able to eat before the
fight and Harper what are you bringing
to the table well I'm a woman who dates
women so I know what we want what do
they want it is there like a new kind of
flower Eliot I'm conducting the
interview okay sorry Harper is there
some kind of new flower no there are no
new flowers physical attractions
important oh yeah dude but it's not as
important as a mental connection okay so
how would you convince them that I'm
capable of doing that you have to
actually be able to have one of those
right
but like until I can you would is your
version of wingmanning just tricking
women into liking you well I mean they
figure out what I'm like pretty quickly
but you're fine with wasting their time
and emotional energy until then well I
feel like I deserve a rebound rebounding
isn't real it's like the tooth fairy
what do you consider yourself a man of
your word Cailin
I'd hardly consider myself a man if I
weren't good okay
so you wanna go on a trial run go over
to Barnes & Noble the ArcLight or veggie
grill or physical contact
hey that is unfair okay that's obeying
the letter of the law but not the spirit
Minelli let's go oh okay I gotta go a to
Brutus a - I'm sorry I was gonna help
Kaelyn be terrible to people oh that's
all right he just wanted a friend yeah
so are we friends no not yet but I'd set
you up one of my friends really yeah
like one that likes boys something that
like boys and girls oh wow oh well start
slow okay I mean you're a good guy so I
wouldn't lie about it
Thanks Harper I mean I wouldn't mention
that whole nail biting thing but I guess
not mentioning something is technically
not
well well I did get prescription gloves
for that cool yeah don't wear those on
the date of course hey you know I've
never done there
see you around Ethan telly it I have a
lesbian wingman I am NOT your wingman
okay wait what
who's been leaving dirty coins under my
pillow
take that